friends this is a wonderful morning
liberal Democrats making big gains
across the country
we've beaten the conservatives in bath
and in Brentwood in Hertfordshire and in
Hinckley
we're making gains of Labor we've
increased our majority in Hull
and we're making huge gains across the
country against the conservatives we're
continuing to make sure the Blue World
tumbles down
[Applause]
and I'm so proud of the result here in
Windsor
[Applause]
and I'm so proud that when Katy Perry
and Lionel Richie
enter Windsor Castle
for the coronation concert on Sunday
they'll be going to a ward that's
represented by three brand new liberal
Democrat counselors
[Music]
sent a huge message
and this is so loud that even someone is
out of touch as Rishi sunak can't ignore
we're fed up of waiting so long for the
basics
waiting for hours for an ambulance
days for a GP appointment months and
even years for a Hospital appointment
Waiting in Vain for the police to turn
up when there's been a breaking
waiting for months for a pothole to be
mended and repaired
waiting for real action to help people
who are struggling with their soaring
energy bills and food prices
and waiting still waiting for those
hospitals that have been promised for
years now
waiting waiting waiting for an end to
the sewage that these companies keep
pouring into our Rivers onto our beaches
and we're waiting for the government to
listen to people
stop taking them for granted
people are waiting for a fair deal
these conservative MPS are out of touch
out of ideas and out of excuses
yay people are fed of waiting for a
chance to kick them out we're all Fed Up
of waiting for a general election
foreign